The second trailer for "Ghostbusters: Afterlife"
is finally here, and there's a ton for fans
to unpack in this glimpse at the latest "Ghostbusters"
story.
Here's some of the details only true fans
noticed in the latest "Ghostbusters: Afterlife"
trailer.
In the trailer, a black and white photo of
the four original Ghostbusters is shown.
They're posing in front of their firehouse.
This photo appears to have been taken on the
set of the first movie.
Based on the clothing they're wearing, it
was probably taken on the day that the Ghostbusters
were visited by spiteful EPA inspector Walter
Peck.
He winds up shutting down the containment
unit holding all the ghosts they've captured,
causing an explosion that frees all the trapped
vapors, entities, and slimers.
As hundreds of spirits escape and begin creating
mayhem all over New York City, the Ghostbusters
are arrested.
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife" will focus largely
on characters who are new to the franchise,
but the latest "Ghostbusters: Afterlife" trailer
includes two appearances from some familiar
characters.
The trailer's first cameo comes courtesy of
Annie Potts, who can be seen reprising her
"Ghostbusters" role as Janine Melnitz.
The former Ghostbusters receptionist appears
to be giving Carrie Coon's Callie a tour of
the creepy farmhouse left to her and her children
by her late father, Egon Spengler.
"Janine, someone with your qualifications
would have no trouble finding a top flight
job in either the food service or housekeeping
industries."
Potts doesn't appear again throughout the
rest of the trailer, but her appearance acts
as an efficient way to connect "Afterlife"
to the original two "Ghostbusters" films.
The familiar manner in which Janine refers
to Egon also suggests that Janine could possibly
be the mother of Coon's Callie, which could
potentially make her Egon's wife and partner.
Janine and Egon did share a romantic spark
in the first "Ghostbusters" film, but Potts'
character went on to date Louis Tully in "Ghostbusters
2."
Still, it's possible "Afterlife" will reveal
that Janine and Egon ended up getting together
some time after the events of "Ghostbusters
2."
Or Janine could just be giving Callie a tour
of the farmhouse as an old family friend.
Either way, the scene is a fun nod to the
connection that Janine and Egon had in the
first "Ghostbusters."
The "Ghostbusters: Afterlife" trailer appears
to give us a few hints as to what evil is
at the center of the film.
When Phoebe peers over the edge of what appears
to be an active volcano, an arm suddenly reaches
out.
Sharp-eyed fans may notice that the figure's
electricity-laden arm and spiky hair is reminiscent
of Gozer, the extremely powerful, supernatural
being who was introduced in the original "Ghostbusters"
movie.
In the first "Ghostbusters," Gozer takes the
form of the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man and
wreaks havoc on New York City before being
blasted to smithereens by the Ghostbusters.
Gozer also had two loyal subjects who were
central to the "Ghostbusters" universe — Vinz
Clortho the Keymaster and Zuul the Gatekeeper.
If Gozer does in fact return for "Ghostbusters:
Afterlife," it's possible that its minions
will return, too.
The "Afterlife" trailer is partly framed by
a conversation between Callie and Mr. Grooberson
over dinner as the single mother explains
the dynamic she has with her children.
She gets on fine with her son Trevor, but
she has a fraught relationship with her daughter
Phoebe.
It's not clear whether Callie and Mr. Grooberson
are on a date or not, but it wouldn't be surprising
if their roles are a bit bigger than the trailers
have implied so far.
The 1984 film established that two entities
are needed to free Gozer: the Gatekeeper and
the Keymaster.
Zuul possesses Dana Barrett in the original,
while Vinz Clortho takes over Louis Tully.
With Gozer seemingly threatening Summerville
in "Ghostbusters: Afterlife," the malevolent
entity will likely need two new hosts to open
the gateway once again.
Since Callie and Grooberson have struck up
some kind of rapport, it's possible that the
sequel is setting them up to be the new Gatekeeper
and Keymaster.
Officially known as Terror Dogs in the original
film, "Ghostbusters'" iconic monsters look
like giant, horrifying dogs with horns and
demonic, glowing eyes.
The Terror Dogs were used by Gozer to possess
Dana Barrett and Louis Tully, turning them
into its servants.
Now, it seems the Terror Dogs are back to
wreak havoc in Summerville.
In the trailer, we see a dog break through
the doors of a Walmart and chase a frightened
Mr. Grooberson through the parking lot.
We don't know if this dog is Zuul or Vinz
Clortho, or an entirely new creature.
Either way, it's clear this Terror Dog isn't
likely to play nice.
"Nice doggy.
Cute little pooch.
Maybe I got a milkbone."
Clearly, "Ghostbusters: Afterlife" is leaning
into the mythology of the first movie through
the apparent returns of both Gozer and the
Terror Dogs.
When Egon explains the history of Gozer and
its worshippers, he says that Ivo Shandor
amassed a cult of nearly a thousand followers
in the 1920s.
"They conducted rituals up on the roof.
Bizarre rituals intended to bring about the
end of the world."
Now, it seems like Ivo may have had a back-up
plan in Summerville, Oklahoma.
In the "Ghostbusters: Afterlife" trailer,
the mines on the edge of town are called the
Shandor Mines.
The trailer briefly shows Trevor and his friends
exploring the mines, which are filled with
ominous statues and occult imagery.
Then, we see a huge cosmic portal swirling
overhead, releasing a horde of ghosts into
the small town.
Perhaps Ivo Shandor himself is responsible
for building the mines, or maybe one of his
followers decided to have a backup plan in
place in case their rituals didn't work.
Perhaps the biggest surprise of the "Ghostbusters:
Afterlife" trailer comes in the last few seconds.
After we see an old commercial for the Ghostbusters
playing on YouTube, we see a phone ring, and
Dan Aykroyd's Raymond Stantz picks up.
We only see his arms, but we instantly know
it's Ray because of his voice when he answers.
"We're closed."
It looks like the former Ghostbuster is still
running his Occult bookstore, as evidenced
by a neon sign for the shop on the window.
Ray first opened the shop when the Ghostbusters
were served a judicial restraining order between
the first and second movies, and fans will
definitely be excited to see him back in the
franchise.
"Ray's Occult.
7:00 on weekdays, midnight on Saturdays.
Thank you."
If you look closely at Ray's arm you'll see
a tattoo that's actually a reference to the
conversation he had with Winston Zeddemore
in the original film where they talked about
a bible verse depicting the end of the world
and how it tied into their work.
"Maybe the reason we've been so busy lately
is the dead have been rising from the grave."
"How about a little music?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.